how's it going breaths my name is beard
ah I feel like [ __ ] today it's fantastic
what a lovely day but we're playing
agario on our private server there's no
one playing on it right now except me
and facepunch
so I'm like all right well I'm gonna
build myself up and then I gotta tweet
out where I am and then I'm gonna eat
you [ __ ] all because I haven't hit
you Chen start look how much food we got
he really wants to kill what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh my god there's just me and
one other guy and he just goes to kill I
mean I was gonna do the same thing
obviously but that is the [ __ ] move
right there all right we're gonna have
to strategize and whatever that is
stride strategy stripes tread strategize
yes we're gonna have to be smart Swift
talented and beautiful everything I am
combined into one solid King also
fabulous this is not as epic as I
thought it would be
oh [ __ ] other people are joining goddamn
it I need to whip a minute to win it all
right hey you can't just keep coming in
here this is the farming game I wish I
wish I was Chinese that would be better
at this no one farms like the Chinese no
one
well I'm sorry [ __ ] Oh goddamn it I
wasn't doing anything I swear it to God
hi there friend welcome to my town
[ __ ] I'm a wolf in sheep's
clothing
like does that facepunch guy have a job
like something he needs to be doing at
this hour
Chet Chet Chet Chet Chet I need your
[ __ ] babies now oh god no no no what
the [ __ ] was that what that [ __ ] was
that I hate you I hope you [ __ ] die
gray I'm last now there's always the big
guy [ __ ] after me every [ __ ] time
never after the bait guy keeps this
[ __ ] sucking dick and [ __ ]
solid King has returned to cleanse these
lands yeah
hoo hoo play how how how are you how do
you have time to just play alone it like
I was gonna do the same thing but I it's
kind of my job you know is it your job
to be an [ __ ] is that it oh god he's
standing on these are me now
Oh interesting come on man I thought we
were having fun man llama shotgun dumb
Chinese man oh yeah who's the real solid
turn
I'm so sorry I don't know what happened
no one no one is allowed on these lands
except the salad king this is what you
get this is what you get oh the salad
king all and my nipples are on fire
right now
oh my you have so many babies there
would be a shame if something happened
to them
when did the question move from why are
we going to war - who is this man's wife
all right I'm gonna Facebook out look
how many people holy [ __ ] for us that's
awesome I can actually like see pretty
good overview cuz I'm this allocate
salvaging oh yes all my dreams are
coming true I get to murder my fat sense
salad game oh oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
stop stop stop what it what what do you
do what do ya